in den usa sorgen postsendungen mit
sprengsätzen an trump kritiker zwei
wochen vor den us-kongresswahlen für
entsetzen
sie wurden unter anderem an den
demokratischen ex präsidenten barack
obama
die frühere präsidentschaftskandidatin
hillary clinton und den
nachrichtensender cnn adressiert zu
schaden kam durch die sprengsätze
niemand us präsident donald trump
spricht von abscheulichen taten und ruft
die usa zu geschlossenheit auf zugleich
übt er aber erneut scharfe kritik an den
medien
medien haben auch eine verantwortung
einen gemäßigten ton anzuschlagen und
die endlose feindseligkeit und die
ständigen negativen und oft falschen
attacken und geschichten zu beenden das
müssen sie sie müssen es beenden und
menschen zusammenbringen dem präsidenten
wird selbst von vielen kritikern
vorgeworfen durch seine oft aggressive
rhetorik das politische klima
aufzuheizen und die spaltung in der us
gesellschaft zu vertiefen